Here at Optimum, we recently found out...
...that our phone number is one number different than Michael Bolton's.
How many calls do you actually get, say, perhaps in a day?
Sometimes 742 phone calls in one day.
Hello?
It's just maddening.
So Optimum and Michael Bolton got together to clear things up...
...for the sanity of Michael Bolton.
How is it actually affecting your personal life?
I don't have a personal life since my number became so close with Optimum.
I tried to have dinner the other night....
...with a lovely woman who has never heard the phone ring as much in her life.
This is too much.
It's too much.
So if you could tell all those people that are calling you right now,...
...that are calling you by accident, what would you say to them?
Please don't call me.
Please.